На все - лише 38 секунд.
Рухи відточені до автоматизму:
спуститися пожежним стовпом і вдягти захисний костюм.
Його вага - 15 кілограмів.
У дівчат залишилося ще 20 секунд, аби
сісти в машину й виїхати за викликом.
Лише хвилина на збори.
Цей норматив виконують усі пожежні України.
- Ми цього з дівчатами навчилися дуже швидко.
Приблизно за 5 годин був повністю відпрацьований  норматив.
Це один із перших в Україні пожежних експериментальних загонів.
Номер один - Ірина, номер два - Дар’я.
Номер три - Сабіна і номер чотири - Анастасія.
Із майже 100 курсанток Харківського університету
цивільного захисту вони стали першими, хто захотів
спробувати бути пожежними. Таке бажання,
приміром, в Ірини виникло ще в 10 років, коли вона
одного разу побачила, як пожежні гасили на трасі машину, що палає.
- Я з таким захопленням і враженням на них дивилася,
на те, як вони швидко це робили, на те, якою
їхня робота була злагодженою.
Спостерігала за всім цим, мріяла, якби я колись
так само, як вони ліквідувала б цю надзвичайну ситуацію.
Жінка, яка гасить пожежі. Подібне в Україні
до грудня минулого року взагалі було неможливим.
Існував цілий список із 450 професій, якими жінкам
прямо заборонялося займатися. Але цей наказ
був скасований Мінохоронздоров'я, тож тепер жінки
можуть працювати разом із чоловіками
на небезпечних роботах. Але для цих дівчат
є нормою робити такий собі виклик чоловікам.
Ірина легко тримає цей рукав з потужним напором води.
Вона - легкоатлетка і чемпіонка Держслужби з надзвичайних ситуацій з бігу.
- Віджимаюся 25 разів. Стометрівку пробігаю за 14,2 секунди.
Особистий рекорд на кілометрі був 3:20.
А це - Сабіна. Кандидатка в майстри спорту з кікбоксінгу.
Чемпіонка України з військово-спортивного орієнтування.
Вона зможе і людину з пожежі витягти,
і важке обладнання принести разом із
бронзовою чемпіонкою світу з гирьового спорту Анастасією.
Вона легко може більше 100 разів підняти 24-кілограмову гирю,
тож тягати оце все для неї неважко.
- Мені завжди хотілося показати чоловікам,
що я не гірша, що можу бути рівною з ними.
А також самій собі, що я можу це зробити.
Це, звичайно, не реальна пожежа, а тренувальна.
У справжньому вогні дівчата ще не були.
І не факт, що потраплять, адже
Держслужба з надзвичайних ситуацій України
поки не готова брати на роботу пожежниць.
Це показала мешканка Львова Юлія Яригіна, яка
вирішили спробувати стати пожежницею,
прийшла до частини, отримала відмову. І лише після
розголосу в соцмережах перед нею вибачилися
і врешті дозволили пройти тести для відбору.
Чи вдасться їй стати пожежницею? Увесь свій шлях
жінка обіцяє описувати на своїй сторінці у Facebook.
Держслужбі з надзвичайних ситуацій ще треба
багато чого змінити. Переписати розраховані
на чоловіків інструкції відбору, підготовки,
алгоритми роботи в надзвичайній ситуації та навіть
подумати, де ж розміщувати жінок у пожежних частинах.
Крім того, уряду, Верховній Раді треба подумати,
як реально дозволяти жінкам працювати
на небезпечних роботах, враховуючи наявність
43-ї статті Конституції, яка це прямо забороняє.
Над цим уже працюють жіночі громадські організації
та відповідальні за гендерні зміни в уряді й силових структурах.
Це робота кількох років. І наскільки це буде швидко,
залежить у тому числі від самих жінок, вважає
керівник харківського жіночого загону.
- На сьогоднішній день гострої потреби
в жінках-рятувальниках я не бачу. І черги з жінок
у пожежних частинах я також не бачу.
У Держслужбі з надзвичайних ситуацій працює
понад 8 тисяч жінок. Ґендерні зміни там
запроваджують уже кілька років, мають результат:
жінок-інспекторів, психологинь побільшало.
А от саме з вогнем мають справу одиниці.
Як Анастасія Клочко, яка працює вже кілька місяців
рятувальницею у Черкасах.
Ці курсантки харківського університету не впевнені,
що будуть працювати після навчання саме пожежницями.
- Можливо, є такі дівчата, які готові та мріяли про це.
Але раніше не можна це було втілити в життя.
І подивившись на наш приклад, вони будуть готові працювати пожежницями.
Дівчата сподіваються, що за 3-4 роки
всі чоловічі інструкції ДСНС будуть переписані й під жінок,
а в пожежних частинах побільшає колег, які
вже не мислять стереотипом про "місце жінки - на кухні".